so apparently Misha Collins was only
supposed to be on three episodes of this
show but they liked him so much they
kept him around was pretty cool that's
funny because you were originally
supposed to only be on three videos of
the real rejects but the female audience
thought you were so hot that I decided
to keep you around originally you're
supposed to be killed off hey you know
when the audience wants something the
audience wants something kill me off is
that why some of the other guests
haven't returned not a lot of comment
about that but with that in mind be
prepared for next week's script all
right guys we're gonna watch this video
from our friend Ashe supernatural
conventions puts together do special
vids we got early access to this one
it's called j2m stories and shenanigans
Jared Jensen and Misha Collins is over a
patron we do TV show watch along as for
many of those shows we have reaction
highlights included our main drive is
supernatural so go to our patreon page
today we cover supernatural weekly we
also covered Doctor Who now attack on
Titan death note my hero academia the
movie two heroes included Code Geass
Hunter hunter one punch man Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood there also many
shows that we do watch alongs
those our ages of shield Gotham Cobra
Kai season two ranger thing season three
Game of Thrones final season black
mirror season five haunting a hill house
the Mandalorian if that was tiresome for
you to look at imagine me reading it
let's do this what was the most
memorable moment Frey that it changed
from a working friendship to a
friendship to making it a family
I don't know if I can beat a question
that was a great question um I I have
this thing that I do which I think I've
shared with you this before but I have
this thing that I do which is every year
around New Year's and I write down my
goals and I think it's a like goals for
the year you want to do for the year and
the year that I got on supernatural I
broke down the goal the goal that I had
that year was I want to now get my buddy
a series regular on a show
with a cast that becomes my lifelong
friends and I don't know why I picked
that thing to say about exaust show
because it really isn't necessarily part
of the career move but I did and I was
actually just thinking about that day or
today it's like that's really strange
because I actually feel like you guys
and this whole room so remarkably tight
group of people we love hanging out with
each other and it's been a gradual
evolution to get to that point like we
all have grown to know and like and
trust each other over time more and more
but I I personally feel like we really
have something very special in this cast
the extended cast I mean all the people
that show up at these conventions are
people I loved and that wasn't wasn't
fast and it didn't happen at a moment he
hated each other quite sometime
there was a moment when you were like
how when I make those lists I need to be
much more specific it's you know it's a
series of events I think that leads to
friendships you know you can meet
somebody and right away have an instant
connection or you can meet somebody and
be like Adams that has a cool person
what am i hanging out with and then that
opportunity presents itself and then now
you you've just furthered that
relationship and because relationships
need to be nurtured and
which we are when you know when you have
a show that that has fortunately been on
as long as it has you're able to nurture
relationships properly and I think that
that's sure you have the right people
nurturing those relationships you get
friendships and that's what we have we
found and not only with you know a few
people with a lot of people I know and
you know that it one of the moments that
did because it was like bad angles like
that's me that was like one of those
moments that kind of furthers a
relationship into a friendship was he
and I were into each other we went for a
dinner out of the where we gas down
kneel down and we sat down with his
hands we sat down on his chewy
table and it was this really cool bar
and the waitress came up and she says
that you guys know what you want and
Misha takes my menu out of my hands
takes his menu hands up to her goes will
take the three least ordered items on
the menu
[Laughter]
[Music]
now that would be fine if it was you
know a burger joint or you know a
steakhouse or something to that degree
this was like a very kind of New Age
kind of a restaurant have what rain we
had sweetbreads which is basically fried
plans I'm like man man this friendship
is gonna be a lot of work right now and
I think it's moments like that that
we've been able and very fortunately
enough to have and those those really
you know they solidify friendships and
that's what we're very thankful to have
so is what you told me earlier
Wow you say that
[Laughter]
of course
Jared thank you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the right type I know cuz we just saw
the episode Jimmy and you realized you
were right
that's what you get for taking too long
of a pause nope
at first they were both kind of like you
know you certainly didn't a lot better
in the beginning I just trying to try to
get in you are you can't I actually the
other day I was doing one of your eyes
for all the wisdom and knowledge in the
world would you do it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
like the journey to take hidden wisdom
and the knowledge is where the wisdom
and knowledge comes from I think it's
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
there is a bit of a version of I think
or at least pace of what the show would
look like if it were on another network
or streaming site that that didn't have
the chance to practice instead the
network's do and that's the same guy you
would probably just see much more
grotesque killings and we were just we
always try to turn it up as loud as we
make it under the you know the ceiling
of what the network's put on us and what
you would you go over to those cable
networks said they deliver that serious
so you could see what like the
outrageousness that you know when he was
on the toilets and I think he would love
to have had that freedom on on
supernatural wa-wait he's just saying I
think that I think the characters
language would be much more colorful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've noticed they can take I'm like it's
just a name like Richard
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
like you slim down you know
Oh
I was in my trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
Jared what characteristics of Dean do
you see in yourself and Jensen what
characteristics of Sam's do you see in
yourself god I do love classic cars car
oh really that's it that's why eat
everything
I am the eater yeah that's that is true
they're like ooh gum gummy bears - true
and I'm just leaving him there like I
didn't eat all bag I guess doing some
more though and lunch you know I I
probably relate to Sam with I tend to be
more analytical then Dean Dean is kind
of a shoot first ask questions later
whereas I I tend to kind of overthink
things and I'm a little slower making
quick decisions and I think Sam is very
kind of deliberate with his with his
thoughts and process and he kind of you
know hashes things out whereas Dean's
like you know who cares let's just do it
let's I'm sure there's many things but
that one comes to mind I would next
question yes I still have the highest
regard for for date is where I got my
starts where I learned a ton I think
it's an amazing medium very very
difficult most people don't realize that
they shoot we shoot about seven eight
pages of
scripted day they shoot 60 to 70 pages
Jesus scripted a that's a lot of
memorization I mean I remember on
average I was to 20 pages of dialogue so
it is it's a really really yeah you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no no I don't think so I think it's a
wonderful we often talk about how it's
not an enormous it's not like we have 20
million viewers who see us every day of
the week or every week of whatever it is
Sam and Dean it's just but who the
people who know us you know
no we don't we don't we don't get as
many viewers obviously is I don't
there's a chalk or this or that but
people who know us care about the show
and I think will give us the benefit of
the doubt if we do something else and
watch it they might not might be like
you're better than your Sam yeah but
don't tell me I was better when I was
Dean or something we have I can watch
these all day I don't know how he's just
like it's like we're not even filming I
wanted to go to a convention more than I
do when I watch the rest of their lives
doing conventions yeah man someday we
can pay for their other crap because I
never want to see them as anyone else
no [ __ ] last bit it's critically if I
was going off of the last thing they
were talking about about being typecast
cuz they're all it's why I might see me
looking down sometimes I like to write
notes on the long videos just nerdy for
me to remember my song I had one of the
things I wrote down was watch
personalities then show I write like to
some random words that help me like
remember what I meant by that was I find
it really interesting how a lot of the
times when I watch the personalities of
people so much and like interviews or
whatever it can actually make it a
little bit challenging for myself to
just get fully invested into them being
the characters again I become aware of
filming I become aware of scene work and
become aware of how they're different
usually what helps is if like they're
like doing a voice on the show you know
like your makeup yeah like your watch
Hugh Laurie at an interview that you
watch them on house and I thought it was
really fascinating how we got like two
shows going on one is like the cut
supernatural convention and then it's
seamless to just watch this series you
know you're watching these actors but
you're also heavily invested in the
characters and the show and I really get
the dynamic that they're referring to of
how the series is not the most popular
thing in the world but it's
fan base is so loyal and a lot of credit
goes to the fact of how you can watch
these guys in interviews and you get
invested in who they are as people but
then you're also super invested in the
storyline so to that extent I see how
supernatural is taking up so much of
their time and their like set for life
with residual income and being able to
do conventions that ever they want I do
think they can branch out and do other
roles after supernatural especially
because as much as there are
similarities between the characters they
play they're also very different in so
many ways and the fact that you can buy
them in the show while being able to
just watch their personalities shows
that no these guys are actually
fantastic actors because you get to know
them so well of who they are at least
the personalities that present at
conventions and you get to see them beat
different human beings on the show
showcasing yeah these guys really can
act so I don't think they are Typekit I
it's like maybe in some ways they're
typecast but I also think they can do
probably a wide variety of roles more
than they've been offered - yeah I feel
like there's probably some more
opportunity for them to expand now that
supernatural is wrapping up and I think
Jared Padalecki is already starring in a
rebooted walker series if I'm not
mistaken or something but it's like if
you look back into like the late 2000s
when Supernatural was kind of in the
midst of things I feel like they were
more typecast when you had Jensen Ackles
and Jared Padalecki both doing like a
slasher reboot in the same year so I
feel like at the height maybe of
Supernatural fever perhaps they would
have been typecast but yeah I think now
when they can you know let the show fade
out my hope is that they'll yeah be able
to stretch their legs out more and maybe
try movies or things like that yeah and
one thing I really appreciated through
this video and it was cool because you
pointed out that this has been kind of
like a sideshow it really has been like
a sideshow cuz at least one of those
stories you know we heard the other side
of in a previous one about like Misha
what was your first impression of Jared
and Jensen and we already heard what
their first impression of him was and I
really like that thing he said at the
beginning where he just put it out there
that he wanted to find a show that would
become like a second family and what I
loved is that that seems to not only
happen for him and the cast and the crew
at least that we're aware of but also
just the the fans and the peep
around it because like I don't imagine
that every show has the convention
presence that supernatural does I mean
supernatural has its own conventions but
then they can also show up inside of a
comic-con well they have an immunity
yeah yeah yeah that's very apparent and
very like tangible yeah I love hearing
stories of when celebrities or you know
successful people write down their goals
and they really envision it and they
accomplish it that's always inspiring to
me goes to support that Law of
Attraction thing that you always hear
about and one thing I was definitely
noticing was the difference in dynamic
maybe it's not so so present here with
Jared and Jensen as it has been in the
other videos you've seen in them but the
difference in dynamic that both Jensen
and Jared have with Misha Collins they
seem a lot more loose yeah with him and
it's not to say there's like a tension
between Jared and Jensen dude the vibe I
get is that there's a bit of a
competitive nature and with Jared and
Jensen like the brotherly dynamics
feather brothers are both like the to
equal stars of the show yes so sometimes
it feels like even with the humor there
seems to be like this competitive thing
they have with one another whereas with
Misha Collins
they both are a lot more hands-on a lot
more attentive but also a little more
goofy they're more goofy they really
like look at him a lot even freaking
Jensen Ackles
I've always noticed how he laughs it a
couple things that Jared Padalecki does
in this video yeah but a lot of the time
he's not really laughing at Jared's
jokes it seems like that part of the bit
is that they're not laughing at what
they're saying like it's that
competitive nature whereas she seems
incredibly loose with Asia Colin's yeah
and you do get that camaraderie
environment I wonder if like the
Brotherly dynamic the fact that they're
both the two leads on Supernatural
creates just a different interaction
with something like because Misha
Collins his personality just feels so
different than theirs
oh yeah it's interesting because we we
first shows up on the show as a Castiel
I imagine a very Siri
for girl I'm pretentious kind of
personality of
who Misha Collins might be who talks
just like that or who's like yeah like
serious and I'm sure he's a he's a
serious actor he's a very talented actor
and we just did watch the episode that
gives the detail origin of the body to
castle and habits of this Jimmy
individual watch this the perfect time
because we were actual supposed to watch
it earlier this week and then we ended
up watching that supernatural episode
just yesterday and that's going up on
patreon today
so to be able to watch where you do see
like he did an amazing job playing this
Jimmy character and then he's also
amazing as Cassio he can morph in a boat
and if anything he's more like Jimmy
sorts is like this very endearing
personality someone who's very
charismatic and I love seeing how
different of an interaction they have
with them because I think before
watching that Jimmy episode I probably
wouldn't have been as excited to see so
many videos of just like oh this is just
Jared ameesha this is just Jensen and
Misha but now I'm like I I'm really
invested in who Misha Collins the
personality is oh yeah well I'm seeing
him and also cuz we've seen yeah a few
of these witches Jared and Jensen up
until this point you know to have his
presence there like he does have a
different vibe and he's almost like a
oddly he's he's the one I wanted to just
like kick it with the most head of this
video because he seems like a teddy bear
kind of guy yeah and it's funny also to
know that yeah he plays one of the most
serious kind of glorious purpose
burdened characters and yeah yeah I have
to know he's the guy who's like always
giggling it's just fun yeah one thing
that did pop in my head at some random
point yesterday cuz I know Kripke left
the show after a certain amount of
seasons and he was the one who
originated this series and I like I love
the show the boys and I've always kind
of wondered what is the relationship
that Eric Kripke has had with Jared
Padalecki and Jensen Ackles if there's
been any like tension for the fact that
they stayed on the show sometimes weird
[ __ ] like that happens drama we don't
really fully know about like they didn't
want to add but Kripke did you know yeah
something like that you can usually
create some type of strife and so I
thought it was really awesome just to
hear that Jensen Ackles actually watched
all of the boys and to have that
experience of going
he's doing the thing that Eric trippy
wanted to do which is this amount of
energy and gore and likening the
personalities go yeah this is more of
the show that he wanted supernatural to
actually be like and I thought it was
pretty cool that they're even surprised
by how much violence they can get away
with no they're constantly like how they
get away with this network yeah yeah
like that is so gory they do that mean
and sick and gross yeah and then for
them to like celebrate that we did it we
got away with this really violent thing
yeah this was very rewarding and
extremely engaging it's amazing to me
how a lot of times you know when we're
gonna go watch like some twenty minute
video didn't have a camera pointer does
the whole time I'll be like really
wanted everyone's like a TV show more
we're accustomed to it or something like
this yeah really be that engaged for
that long but these just like to keep
going I just want to be there yeah
because yeah is now you have that thing
of like we're already familiar with them
because we see them every week and now
they actually get that relief of just
chumming with them like I hope the
supernatural gets rebooted in a you know
like 10 years as a daytime soap so that
they can keep doing this forever all
right guys what other kind of characters
do you want to see Jared Padalecki and
Jensen Ackles explore now that
supernatural is over leave your thoughts
down below what other genres perhaps
subscribe to the real rejects click the
notification bell make sure to check us
out on patreon and last but not least
let's end this with up 4lb that's right
lb has been one of our most gracious and
most dedicated followers over on our
patreon we love you to death to death I
mean that and as such you know here on
your shout out I decided to write some
rhymes of my own because why should
Gregorio have all the fun I can rhyme I
can rap I mean he does more like poems
for these but this will be like kind of
a rap poem cuz I don't have a beat but
this is for you l this is my thoughts
and my feelings and my appreciation for
you so one two three I got some rhymes
for L Beach having frequently on the
patreon comments about our stream and
lungs of BTS songs thoughtful as the day
is
she's a woman with perspective and
imagination if given the option I take
an lb class as an elective gonna be in
my education then at graduation I'll
take a page out of the Greg Alba book
look up your name and I'm shook because
L mean she so this must mean the she who
goes by lb must be the fairest lady in
all of our paint tree on now my times
almost done Homer back in the head stay
awesome lb rock on and and don't degrees
your pledge Greg will beat me